do you think that people over complicate
motivation
yes
i find that
discussions about motivation a lot of
the time i mean you are the uh
soundtrack to a lot of motivation
compilation
uh video that's right yeah uh
motivation universe 40 minute get up and
get after it
jocko video um
so i i think that a lot of the
discussions about motivation can cause
people to believe
that there's some magical state that
they need to be in
before they do something
yeah and as i've said since day one it's
motivation is a feeling that comes and
goes and it doesn't matter whether it's
there or not discipline is infinitely
more important so no matter how you feel
get up and do what you're supposed to do
that's it and that's discipline it's not
motivation if you only did
what you were supposed to do when you
were motivated to do it that's leaving
it to chance
but if you're disciplined you go to what
you're supposed to do that's the way it
works
i went and listened to an episode you
did with sam harris
seven years ago now long time ago
he came up with this a really
interesting idea where he said that you
can't fake courage yeah
that's one of the most interesting ways
to look at it he said that
courage or bravery i think is actually
what he was
talking about you it's an emotion that
you can't fake if you fake bravery when
you're terrified
that is bravery
and i kind of feel like motivation is
the same thing if you do the thing when
you're feeling unmotivated that is
motivation that's it so are you saying
that all of the jocko videos of
motivation they can just go off of
youtube well i i i say in a lot of those
videos and sometimes that's what it
takes for people to get motivated is to
realize that that motivation doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's a
self-defeating video just shut up and go
do what you're supposed to do
yeah i mean the difference between the
person that spends all day weren't
wondering about
whether they should go to the gym or not
and the person that just goes to the gym
or not even if they both go
they net out at zero apart from the fact
that one person has spent the entire day
obsessing over it yeah and probably
wasting some brain power on it does this
thing called the bro science called the
anxiety cost so you know opportunity
cost right that you because of doing one
thing you can't do another thing
anxiety cost to me is the wasted mental
effort that you go through obsessing
over something when you could fix it
quite easily by just doing it it's one
of the
most compelling reasons for doing a
morning training workout for me if you
go to train every day every morning when
you wake up your daily to-do list resets
right you get out of bed and then your
to-do list of
meditate and walk the dog and answer
emails and do all that
the sooner that you can front load that
stuff
the rest of the day is just
yeah discipline equals freedom
that's it i mean if you have the
discipline to get up and get the things
done
well i i've i usually i often tell a
similar story this is the same thing
that you just said which is hey you know
the weekend where you really only had
two things to do for the weekend
whatever it was you had to write this
thing
and you had to answer this other thing
and on friday you're like i'll do it
tomorrow and on saturday like i'll do it
and it's basically hanging over your
head the whole weekend whereas if you're
just done friday afternoon the whole
weekend would have been a lot better
so just do the thing
i agree with you just do it just
do the thing man what does courage mean
to you is that a good definition from
sam do you think doing doing the thing
in spite of the way that you feel
yeah i think that's i think that's solid
i i i
somebody asked me a question the other
day does courage have to involve risk
and i thought about it a little bit i
haven't thought i don't sit around and
think about a lot of stuff
uh which might be obvious i guess but
yeah i think if you're gonna if you're
gonna get credit for courage then there
has to be some level of risk whether
it's you know
capital risk and doing something in
business or
physical risk if you're doing something
to run into a fire to save somebody yeah
so i think
i think courage has to have some kind of
risk involved and then yes i agree with
sam harris
when he pointed out that if you're
acting if you're doing the thing then
that's courage no matter how you feel
inside your your little brain what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
oh